>>Winnie Lam: Hello everyone, thank you so
much for coming.
I'm Winnie Lam and it is my absolute pleasure
to welcome our speakers today, Jenny Ross
and Kassie Siegel who is at the back there
with a big polar bear [laughs].
So let me introduce our speakers.
Jenny Ross is an award winning photographer.
She has won many, many photography awards
specializing in wildlife and conservation.
Her most recent award is the World Press Photo
Award which is kinda like the Oscars for photo
journalism, so it was a really big deal.
Her photographs have been exhibited at the
local California Academy of Sciences and at
the Smithsonian National Museum of Natural
History.
Our former President, Bill Clinton, also has
her photographs in his private collection,
so that's really cool.
Kassie Siegel is the director of the Climate
Law Institute at the Center for Biological
Diversity.
She sought to protect the polar bear by listing
it as an endangered species under the Endangered
Species Act.
Prior to her becoming a lawyer at the Berkeley
Law School she was leading trips in Alaska
for Natural History.
So without further ado let's give a very warm
welcome to our guests today, Jenny Ross and
Kassie Siegel.
[applause]
>>Jenny Ross: Hi everybody, I appreciate your
being here today.
It's really a pleasure and an honor to have
the opportunity to speak with you and to share
some of my photographs with you.
Kassie and I are going to try to cover quite
a bit of ground in a short amount of time
today, so if you have questions as we go along
please do try to remember your questions and
then when we're finished we'll try to answer
them for you.
So have any of you ever seen a wild polar
bear in its natural habitat?
Oh a couple people.
Fantastic, excellent.
Well I hope that the rest of you do get that
opportunity someday, it's truly an amazing
experience.
About 12 years ago I saw and photographed
polar bears for the first time in the wild
and of course I was absolutely captivated
by how magnificent looking they are, but I
was also fascinated by how they managed to
live seemingly comfortably in such an extreme
and really totally alien world of ice.
Their ability to thrive in one of the harshest
environments on earth is truly awe inspiring.
So at this point I've spent literally thousands
of hours in the Arctic in various regions
and I've photographed polar bears throughout
the Arctic in all five of the Arctic countries.
In addition I've had the privilege of working
with and, so I've also had the privilege of
working with and learning from many of the
world's foremost experts on polar bear biology
as well as experts on a variety of other subjects
relating to the Arctic and to climate change.
So in addition to talking a bit about photography
with you I'd like share some of the knowledge
that I've gained over the years particularly
regarding polar bear biology, ecology, and
behavior.
In addition I'd like to discuss some issues
that I feel are extremely important, really
crucial actually, concerning the impacts of
climate change in the Arctic.
But first I'd like to tell you some things
about my photography of polar bears.
For me understanding the science relating
to these truly marvelous animals has not diminished
in the least that feeling of being completely
awe struck that I had when I first photographed
a wild polar bear.
In fact, on the contrary, the more I've learned
about polar bears the more fascinating and
awe inspiring they've actually become for
me.
So in my photography of polar bears I'm not
just trying to capture beautiful images of
beautiful animals, certainly of course I am
trying to achieve that goal, but I'm really
trying to do more than that, much more than
that.
In my images I'm trying to explain the many
things about these remarkable animals that
make them exceptional and endlessly intriguing
and worthy of our respect and our admiration
and of course worthy of our protection as
well.
In addition I want my photographs to communicate
that every bear is a unique individual just
like every one of us.
Human beings have a rather unfortunate tendency
to think of animals essentially as objects
and as fungible, a bear is a bear is a bear,
rather than as unique individuals.
But the reality is that every polar bear has
his or her own unique life history and experiences
and distinctive personality.
So I want people to understand what makes
them tick, how they live their lives on a
day to day basis, and how they manage to not
only survive but to thrive in what is truly
one of the most incredibly harsh places on
the planet.
[pause]
I also feel that it's essential to communicate
in a way that the average non-scientist will
really understand clearly and appreciate at
a gut level that polar bears are truly threatened
fundamentally by disappearing Arctic sea ice
as the result of rising temperatures and that
the situation is getting worse.
[pause]
I believe that photography can be a very powerful
tool for educating people about issues as
to which they would otherwise have no frame
of reference, and they can also be a very
effective tool for inspiring people to have
both an intellectual and an emotional connection
to a subject matter which motivates them to
care about the issues involved.
So my ongoing long term project called Life
On Thin Ice focuses on using photography combined
with science to communicate with the public
and with policy makers about climate change
in the Arctic, about Arctic science issues,
to explain what's happening, and to explain
really why it's crucially important.
So what exactly is happening in the Arctic
and just as importantly why should it really
make a difference to you?
Well to put the matter simply the Arctic really
is ground zero for climate change and it's
undergoing a rapid, dramatic, and frankly
ominous transformation that has very serious
implications for our entire planet.
And in briefly explaining that to you today
I'm gonna focus specifically on polar bears
because they truly are the proverbial canaries
in the coal mine with regard to climate change.
So I'd like to start by discussing some key
misconceptions regarding polar bears because
there are several that are very prevalent
and I think that they cause most people to
believe incorrectly that rising Arctic temperatures
and the disappearance of Arctic sea ice are
really not a huge problem for polar bears,
when in reality those issues actually endanger
the continued existence of polar bears.
So misconception number one: polar bears exist
in a single, large population and all of the
bears essentially wander throughout the entire
Circumpolar Arctic.
Well this incorrect notion tends to lead people
to believe mistakenly that as the Arctic sea
ice melts and disappears in one area polar
bears can simply move to another area where
there's more sea ice.
Before I explain why that's incorrect I wanna
pause just for a moment and make sure we're
all on the same wave length regarding what
portion of the globe we're talking about.
Take a look at this map and [chuckles] I apologize
it's not a Google Earth map, it certainly
should be [chuckle].
So the map shows the entire Northern Hemisphere
region surrounding the North Pole, and the
dotted circle you see there is the Arctic
Circle at approximately 66 degrees north.
So the Arctic is typically defined as the
region north of the Arctic Circle, all around
the North Pole.
So regarding that first misconception about
polar bears, the scientific reality is that
polar bears do not live in a single population
with all of the bears just sort of wandering
throughout that entire Circumpolar Arctic
region.
Instead scientists have determined that there
are actually 19 separate sub populations of
polar bears in the Arctic, and each of these
19 regions represents an area where the circumscribed
home ranges of numerous individual bears overlap
and are concentrated within a discreet geographic
region.
And essentially for the most part the bears
in each of these separate regions remain in
each of these separate regions throughout
their entire lives.
In addition, the bears have very specific
habitat preferences within each of those 19
areas.
The range of polar bears is limited to places
where the ocean is covered with ice or nearly
covered with ice for most of the year.
And the regions where polar bears strongly
prefer to spend as much time as they possibly
can are the areas where the sea ice is over
the shallow continental shelf.
So on this map those shallow continental shelf
regions are designated in white and you can
see that's a subset of that Circumpolar Arctic
region.
So these areas designated in white are the
places where there are the highest concentrations
of polar bear, and that's because those are
the places where the shallow ocean has the
highest degree of biological productivity,
basically where there's a complex, dense web
of life in the sea.
So simply put, these are the areas where polar
bears can find the highest concentrations
of their prey and they can use the ice to
travel on the ocean and to hunt successfully.
[pause]
So misconception number two is that polar
bears are omnivores just like brown bears.
Well the reality is that brown bears are indeed
omnivores but polar bears are obligate carnivores.
This misconception tends to lead people to
believe that as the Arctic sea ice melts and
disappears polar bears can simply shift from
living out on the sea ice to living on land,
no problem.
But that's not correct.
Brown bears eat a wide variety of terrestrial
foods; they eat berries and various types
of vegetation, they eat insects, ground squirrels,
and of course they eat fish.
But the diet of polar bears is completely
different and it must be completely different.
It is essential for polar bears to eat a very
high fat diet consisting of blubbery marine
mammals.
All polar bears in all regions of the Arctic
prey on ice dependent Arctic seals.
In some areas some polar bears occasionally
eat other types of big, fat marine mammals,
for example, walruses if an appropriate opportunity
arises, but for the most part the bottom line
is that polar bears eat seals.
They actually have the capacity to digest
and assimilate 97 percent of the fat that
they eat which is quite remarkable.
And they must have that very high fat diet.
[pause]
Misconception number three: as the Arctic
sea ice melts and shrinks it becomes easier
for polar bears to hunt seals because they
catch their prey in the water.
Well this is absolutely false.
With extraordinarily rare exceptions polar
bears cannot catch their prey in the water;
seals are much too quick and far too agile
when they're swimming and they can very easily
evade a swimming polar bear.
So how do polar bears catch seals then?
Well they use a variety of very interesting
hunting techniques and unfortunately I don't
have the time to tell you about those today
but you're welcome to ask me questions about
that issue later.
But the bottom line, the crucial issue is
that all polar bear hunting techniques rely
in one way or another on the existence of
sea ice.
And in case you haven't spotted where the
polar bear is in this photograph he's right
there in the lower right hand portion of the
frame and he's using the sea ice as camouflage
as he tries to get close to a distant seal
that's lying on the ice.
So regardless of the specific technique used,
polar bears absolutely must utilize sea ice
in some manner in order to hunt successfully.
So in an ice free ocean polar bears simply
cannot catch seals.
They need the sea ice to travel long distances
and to find their prey and they need the ice
to get close to seals in order to stalk them
effectively and they need the ice to actually
catch seals.
Furthermore they need a sea ice platform in
order to feed on their prey.
Remember they're out literally in the middle
of the ocean, they need to have that sea ice
platform.
[pause]
Misconception number four: polar bears are
good swimmers so shrinking ice cover really
is not a problem for them because they can
easily travel from one area that does not
have ice to another area that does have ice
by swimming.
Well it is true that polar bears are excellent
swimmers, they can very easily swim from one
ice floe to another in regions where the ice
is broken and separated by narrow channels
of water such as you see here in this photograph.
But even though polar bears can swim very
well they cannot swim indefinitely and they
can have very serious problems when trying
to swim very long distances.
They can succumb to exhaustion and hypothermia
and they can easily drown in rough seas.
In fact in regions where polar bears have
been forced recently to swim very far in rough
seas because they're trying to reach that
shrinking sea ice, scientists have already
documents a number of instances in which polar
bears have in fact drowned.
In addition it's even more difficult for cubs
to swim long distances than it is for adult
bears.
Cubs have substantially less body fat than
adults and that of course means they're much
less well insulated so of course they get
cold much more easily and they can easily
be incapacitated by hypothermia and drown.
Also having less body fat means that cubs
are less buoyant so it requires a lot more
energy for them to swim and they have a harder
time keeping their heads above the water,
and of course that's particularly true when
the ocean is rough.
[pause]
So the crucial issue to keep in mind is that
polar bears have evolved over many tens of
thousands of years to be uniquely well adapted
physically, physiologically, and behaviorally
for a very specialized, extremely narrow ecological
niche in the Arctic.
In fact they are so perfectly adapted to the
specific extreme conditions in the Arctic
that they actually require sea ice for every
essential aspect of their lives including
traveling, hunting, feeding, resting, finding
mates, and breeding.
So what is happening to the Arctic sea ice
that polar bears and other Arctic animals
depend on that they actually must have in
order to survive?
Well to put the situation bluntly it's melting
and it's disappearing.
And before I explain that issue in a bit more
detail, just as a preliminary matter, I wanna
be sure that you understand a couple of basic
things about Arctic sea ice.
There's an annual cycle during which the Arctic
sea ice naturally grows to some extent and
then shrinks to some degree.
So each year the Arctic sea ice reaches its
annual maximum extent in the late winter in
approximately early March and then after the
summer melt season each year the Arctic sea
ice reaches its annual minimum extent in the
fall in approximately mid-September.
And the most important issue to keep in mind
concerning Arctic sea ice and climate change
is that bright ice cover on the Arctic Ocean
reflects most of the sun's radiation, whereas
dark, open ocean absorbs most of the sun's
energy.
So as the bright, reflective ice cover on
the ocean shrinks and more of the dark, open
ocean is exposed, the sea in that region absorbs
far more of the sun's energy, the water temperature
and the air temperature in that region increase,
and the remaining ice melts more and more
quickly.
And by the way the same principle applies
to disappearing snow cover and ice on dark
land as well.
So what exactly has been happening in the
Arctic to cause the sea ice to shrink?
Well most crucially the concentrations of
heat trapping greenhouse gases in our atmosphere
have dramatically increased and that has led
to rising temperatures.
The global average temperature has been rising
since the Industrial Revolution in the 19th
century, but during the last several decades
it has risen at a particularly significant
rate.
But importantly temperatures in the Arctic
have risen even faster than that; they've
been rising at least twice as fast overall
as temperatures around the globe, the global
average temperature, and in many parts of
the Arctic recently the temperatures have
been rising even more dramatically than that.
Take a look at this NASA color coded map and
I wanna direct your attention specifically
to the upper portion of the map where there's
that huge swath of red all across the Arctic.
So this map shows the temperature anomalies
for all 2011 in relation to the period 1951
to 1980 and as you can see in most of the
Arctic throughout 2011 temperatures were three
to four and a half degrees Celsius higher
than they were just a few decades ago; that's
about five and a half to eight degrees Fahrenheit
hotter in 2011, a very significant rise in
temperature.
So during the past few decades as a result
we have lost immense quantities of Arctic
sea ice; there is no legitimate debate about
that fact.
Scientific data show without a doubt that
Arctic sea ice is unquestionably shrinking
in both extent and in thickness.
When the sea ice reached its annual minimum
extent in September of 2011 that extent was
two point four three million square kilometers
smaller than the average extent that existed
from 1979 through 2000, and two point four
three million square kilometers is about 935,000
square miles; that's a lot of ice lost.
[clears throat]
In addition, the thickness of Arctic sea ice
is decreasing even more dramatically and of
course the thinner the ice the most vulnerable
to further melting it becomes.
The Arctic sea ice has shriveled so much in
thickness that the total volume of sea ice
still remaining at the end of the melt season
in September of 2011 was nearly 70 percent
less than the average volume of sea ice that
existed from 1979 to 2000.
[pause]
It's really difficult to emphasize strongly
enough how significant the recent changes
in the Arctic really are.
During the last 30 years as Arctic temperatures
have risen dramatically approximately 12,000
cubic kilometers of Arctic sea ice has completely
disappeared.
Let me try to give you a sense of how much
ice that really is: imagine that the ice is
in a vast sheet and that sheet has a uniform
thickness of three feet; so 12,000 cubic kilometers
of ice is enough ice to completely cover all
of these countries with three feet thick ice:
the entire United States including Alaska
and Hawaii, Mexico, England, Ireland, France,
Italy, and Germany and there would still be
enough ice left over to cover New Jersey two
more times with ice three feet thick.
That is an enormous volume of ice and it has
completely disappeared.
[pause]
So what's the bottom line for the future of
Arctic sea ice and for polar bears?
Well Dr. Mark Serreze who is the Director
of the U.S. National Snow and Ice Data Center
recently expressed the situation this way
and I'm quoting: "It's quite conceivable that
the tipping point we talk about has already
been reached.
The Arctic summer sea ice is in a death spiral."
[pause]
Unless major action is taken very quickly
to decrease our emissions of heat trapping
greenhouse gas into the atmosphere and to
slow the pace of atmospheric warming, many
scientists who specialize in studying Arctic
sea ice believe that there will be essentially
no summer sea ice remaining within 20 years
and it's possible that most of the ice will
be gone long before that, possibly as quickly
as sometime in the next 10 years.
[pause[
Take a look at this graph for a moment.
[clears throat] A number of Arctic sea ice
experts have recently determined that the
data relating to Arctic sea ice volume actually
reveal an exponential decline rather than
a linear decline.
So as you can see if this trend continues
we may be headed for an ice free Arctic ocean
in the summer within only a matter of a few
years.
So what about polar bears?
Well sadly as I've explained polar bears are
truly dependent on sea ice for every essential
aspect of their lives.
If there is no sea ice they simply cannot
survive over the long term.
And because of the loss of sea ice that has
already occurred due to rising temperatures
already, polar bears are already in trouble
in various regions.
In many parts of the Arctic the amount of
time that polar bears can be out on the Arctic
sea ice hunting seals is decreasing significantly
already basically because the ice in the area
where they live is disappearing.
So many of those bears are being forced to
spend increasingly lengthy period of time
stranded on land and without sea ice, without
the ability to hunt for seals, those polar
bears stranded on land are food deprived.
Now some of those hungry bears may occasionally
nibble on some vegetation which is basically
like one of us nibbling on a few potato chips
and trying to survive on that.
Some of the bears stranded on land may wander
into inhabited areas unfortunately and get
into trouble by searching for food too close
to people, definitely not a good situation
at all.
And some of them may even become so desperately
hungry that they endanger their safety searing
for alternative foods, like this dare devil
polar bear.
I photographed this sub-adult, male polar
bear in Novaya Zemlya in the Russian higher
Arctic and he was stranded on land, food deprived
because the sea ice had disappeared throughout
the entire region and he was trying unsuccessfully
to eat sea bird eggs on this nearly sheer
cliff.
So I was there bobbing up and down in a Zodiac
trying to stabilize my 100 to 400mm lens and
get some pictures of this incredible site,
and my heart was literally pounding in my
throat because I was so worried that this
crazy bear was gonna fall off that cliff.
Thankfully he didn't, but he truly risked
his life climbing on the cliff.
And I think he burned more calories doing
that than he would have gained even if he
had been able to eat some of those sea bird
eggs.
As I explained earlier the simple reality
is that polar bears need to eat a very high
fat diet.
Alternative foods simply cannot sustain them
over the long term.
And recently scientists have been documented
incidents involving polar infanticide and
cannibalism; situations where an adult male
polar bear has killed a younger bear specifically
for food.
Now these tragic occurrences appear to be
rare, but scientists believe that they may
become more common as sea ice increasingly
disappears and it becomes increasingly difficult
for polar bears to hunt for seals.
So as a result of being stranded on land for
increasingly lengthy periods of time and suffering
chronic nutritional stress, in some areas
polar bears are declining in physical condition,
fewer cubs are being born because of the deteriorating
condition of adult female polar bears, survival
rates are being affected in some areas, and
the size of some populations of polar bears
is already declining.
At this point polar bear scientists have determined
that 8 of the 19 polar bear populations in
the world are already declining and all polar
bears in all regions of the Arctic will ultimately
be endangered by loss of their sea ice habitat
if current temperature trends continue.
But it's also very important to keep in mind
that the consequences of this dramatic transformation
that's taking place in the Arctic are not
just a problem for polar bears.
Rising temperatures in the Arctic are affecting
entire ecosystems.
In addition, very importantly what most people
don't realize is that the Arctic plays a very
important role, an essential role, in regulating
our entire planet's climate system.
So the impacts of a rapidly warming Arctic
will ultimately affect every living thing
on earth either directly or indirectly, including
people.
If rising greenhouse gas emissions and rising
temperatures continue to the point that the
Arctic becomes uninhabitable by polar bears
we will have completely transformed the climate
of the entire planet in a very extreme manner.
In fact that climate transformation will be
so extreme that there will be truly devastating
consequences all across the globe for every
ecosystem and every population of people.
So fundamentally these magnificent animals
really are the charismatic canaries in the
coal mine.
Their plight is a clear warning to us that
we must galvanize ourselves into action to
address climate change not only to protect
polar bears and other Arctic animals and not
only to protect countless other species in
ecosystems all across the globe, but ultimately
also to protect ourselves.
So I'm going to leave you with that very sobering
thought and turn this over to Kassie.
Again, thank you very much for being here.
I really appreciate your interest and your
attention and after Kassie's finished I'd
be very happy to answer whatever questions
you have.
Thanks a lot.
[applause]
>>Kassie Siegel: Thank you Jenny and a million
thanks to Winnie for setting this up and to
Google for hosting and for all of you for
coming.
It's really nice to be part of this conversation
today and great to actually see Jenny's presentation;
I haven't seen her give a talk in a number
of years, so that was really wonderful, thank
you Jenny.
We brought me along to talk about the solutions
and the good news because of course there
are things we can do for polar bears.
The two biggies to do for an endangered species
like this: number one remove other threats
that are stressing them in addition to climate
warming to give them a better chance of making
it; and number two, of course, deep, rapid,
and sustained greenhouse gas reductions.
And the good news is that we do actually have
the laws on the books today that require both
those things and so I'd like to very briefly
just do two things: tell the very condensed
story of getting Endangered Species Act listing
for the polar bear, and then saying a few
words about where we're going, where we're
headed next and additional things we need
to do.
There's a couple of great things about the
Endangered Species Act: it is the world's
strongest law for the protection of imperiled
species and it specifically allows any person
to petition to have a species added to the
list of threatened and endangered species,
provides mandatory timelines for the government
to respond and if they don't you can sue them,
and requires all of the decisions that the
government make be made only on the basis
of the best available science.
So we petitioned to list polar bears because
of global warming back in February of 2005,
actually on the day that the Kyoto Protocol
entered into force without the participation
of the United States.
During the Bush Administration of course the
Bush Administration was not eager to list
the polar bear and the other species, was
opposed to this kind of regulation, but because
of these three aspects of the law we were
able to push this petition forward to listing.
The first strategy the government took was
to just ignore the petition; we sued them;
had to sue them twice; won both times and
got mandatory deadlines from the court by
which they had to act.
At that time one of the things we thought
we might have to do was litigate the science
of global warming if the Administration decided
not to list the bear which we thought was
a real possibility; they didn't wanna do it
but we thought we could win in court.
The fact that they tried to ignore it, we
had to sue a couple times, helped us also
get media coverage of that, increase a little
bit awareness of the polar bears' plight which
is an important thing.
Unlike any other species that I've ever work
on there was great suspense, a lot of public
involvement, over three-quarters of a million
people wrote in saying, "Please protect the
bear, we want you to do this."
The eyes of the world were truly on the Administration.
Right up until the day that they had to make
the decision based on the court order we didn't
know what the decision was going to be and
in fact later in litigation that's still going
on we found a memo from the head of the U.S.
Fish and Wildlife Service, which is the wildlife
management agency, he said, "The Assistant
Secretary of the Interior called me," so the
Secretary of the Interior is the final decision
maker and said, "The Secretary is not gonna
list the polar bear."
This was just about a week before the final
decision and I said, "Well alright that's
his decision to make, but I shouldn't be at
the press conference because I can't support
that decision, I think the bear should be
listed."
Somewhere in that week, this was at the very
highest levels of the Administration, the
decision changed and the Bush Administration
did list the bear.
I think that's because they didn't wanna litigate
the science of climate change.
So they listed the bear and this brings some
really strong legal protections: things like
the designation of critical habitat, those
are the areas essential for their survival
and recovery of the bear, and vast areas of
the Arctic Ocean and near shore areas in Alaska
have now been designated as critical habitat.
The oil industry in the State of Alaska and
others are suing over that trying to get it
undesignated and so we're defending it but
that is a big protection.
They have to prepare a recovery plan and they
are doing that now and we hope for the first
time this recovery plan will set out the specific
greenhouse gas reductions that are needed
in order to protect the Arctic sea ice and
protect the bear.
There's also something that requires, all
federal agencies are gonna carry out or approve
an action that might impact the bears to consult
with the Wildlife Management Agency, the U.S.
Fish and Wildlife Service, on the impact of
their action.
This has been a very successful program.
Most species once they're added to the list
have not gone extinct; only two species ever
have become extinct after being listed; very,
very successful.
Global warming of course though poses a new
and overwhelming threat and people often ask,
"Well what's the point really?
The Endangered Species Act can't do anything
about greenhouse gases."
Actually it can; this consultation provision
is one of the areas where we want to see that
happen.
Wildlife management agencies look at ways
to reduce pesticides that harm frogs, mercury
that harms fish, dams that harm salmon, etcetera.
Both the Bush Administration and the Obama
Administration have taken the position that
greenhouse gases are somehow exempt from this
portion of the law.
And we're not arguing that the Endangered
Species Act is a complete solution to global
warming, of course it's not.
It's not even the leading domestic law for
greenhouse reductions, that's actually the
Clean Air Act.
But I think it's a really important point
because for some reason it is a powerful argument
that any given tool is not the best tool or
the right tool for reducing greenhouse emissions.
So for example, opponents will argue, "We
shouldn't be using the Endangered Species
Act, that's not suited, that was not the intent
of the Endangered Species Act for greenhouse
emissions, let's use the Clean Air Act."
But then when we get to the Clean Air Act
they say, "No the Clean Air Act is not the
right tool, let's use a market based cap and
trade program."
But then when we get to having cap and trade
legislation introduced in Congress that legislation
is killed.
So there's a lot of debate over what is the
right tool and I think that the urgency of
the situation clearly requires that we be
using all tools in the box, not arguing about
which one is the best while doing nothing
at all.
The Bush Administration exempted greenhouse
emissions from the reach of the Endangered
Species Act; we've been in litigation over
that.
We did win on that part of the case and that
part of the decision has been sent back to
the Obama Administration for reconsideration
and there will be a public comment period
opening up on that next month.
And we hope that we will have the same level
of involvement in that in having folks say,
"Hey, we really shouldn't exempt the number
one threat to the species from the law."
The other piece of the good news is that we
have the strongest domestic environmental
laws in the world.
The Clean Air Act is actually all set up and
ready to go to reduce emissions from all sectors
of the economy, has been a very successful
law, it is political barriers that we are
facing.
We have widespread non-implementation and
under implementation of our existing laws
for political reasons not for legal reasons,
I think not for technological reasons.
We have so much low hanging fruit we need
deep and sustained emissions reductions, but
through energy efficiency, through existing
technology, and through speeding the development
and deployment of new technology we really
can, we really can solve this problem, we
really do have the legal framework, but we
have to get beyond the political barriers.
That requires involvement from everyone.
I truly don't think that the polar bear would
have been listed as a threatened species had
it not been for involvement, so my plea to
you is to get involved in this in pushing
for action on the climate crisis in whatever
way is most appealing to you.
If you would like to get involved through
the Center I would not be any kind of activist
without my clipboards and so I do have them
here.
They're in the back of the room on that table.
Please do, we have a general sign up sheet,
we have a petition to the EPA which is headlined
by Dr. Jim Hansen, leading scientist at NASA,
Bill McKibben and others asking the EPA to
use the Clean Air Act to reduce greenhouse
gases back to below 350 parts per million;
various other materials, please do take them
they're heavy, we don't produce a lot of paper
but I brought quite a lot today and I will
stop there and I look forward to the discussion.
Thanks so much everybody.
[applause]
Do you wanna come up?
>>male #1: Regarding the Endangered Species
Act and that protection you'd shown a picture
that there's many, many countries in certain
polar regions and so this is only covering
a tiny fraction it seems, the U.S. portion,
so regarding protection for the bear and its
habitat in is it Russia or Canada would seem
to be far more greater in terms of the space
that the polar bear lives, what's going on
in those regions and does it really matter
then if the U.S. has all this great protection
and 90 percent of the terrain not protected?
This seem pretty much a Quixotic effort, chasing
windmills.
>>Kassie Siegel: The bear is actually listed
everywhere.
You can list the worldwide species which is
what happened.
Of course only people subject to the jurisdiction
of the U.S. have their behavior curtailed
by the Endangered Species Act.
The Critical Habitat Designation is actually
only the U.S. land area.
Canada actually has two-thirds of the world's
polar bears and the big conservation issue
in Canada beyond global warming and oil spill
is over hunting.
Unfortunately Canada's the only country in
the world that still allows a trophy hunt
of polar bears and unfortunately even though
hunting was addressed fairly well by the 1973
Polar Bear Treaty, in 1994 the U.S. Marine
Mammal Protection Act was amended to once
again allow the import of trophy hunted polar
bear carcasses into the U.S.
Since that time hunting levels went way, way
up again.
One of the ramifications of the listing under
the ESA was that you can no longer import
trophy hunted polar bears from Canada into
the U.S.
So I think that that hasn't entirely solved
the problem, there's other ways we are trying
to go about that.
In Canada there is certainly a big international
market for polar bear parts but there has
been some benefit internationally and can
be a lot of benefits.
[pause]
>>Jenny Ross: Yes.
>>male #2: Could you elaborate on the ramifications
for the rest of the world if all of the the
Arctic ice were to disappear?
>>Jenny Ross: I'm sorry.
>>Kassie Siegel: Yeah I'm sorry I didn't hear
the first part.
If all the Arctic ice were to disappear --
>>male #2: what would be the implications
for the rest of the world?
>>Kassie Siegel: Oh, great question.
>>Jenny Ross: Yes, yes, yes.
>>Kassie Siegel: [chuckles] Great question,
I think we were both condensing today.
>>Jenny Ross: Yes.
>>Kassie Siegel: It just so happens [chuckles]
that the things we need to do to save the
Arctic ice, I mean the polar bear is worth
saving for itself as a magnificent animal,
but it just so happens that the things we
need to do to save the Arctic sea ice are
the things we need to do to save the rest
of the world as well.
And I'm sure everybody knows, I mean climate
change is here now.
If you live in Bangladesh or you live in the
Sub-Saharan in Africa or you live in the Inuit
community up in the Arctic, I mean rapid climate
change is happening now.
And one of the things I find so exciting about
working on the polar bear is we don't save
the bear without saving the Arctic ice pack
has huge ramifications for the global climate
system.
The Arctic ice pack as Jenny alluded to acts
as the air conditioner for the planet and
when the ice melts it's like unplugging that
air conditioner.
The reflectivity is one of the feedbacks in
the Arctic; release of methane as the permafrost
thaws, another feedback.
If we don't act soon enough to slow these
feedbacks we're looking at impacts like 20
feet of more of sea level rise around the
world.
So it's not that I don't think the polar bear
is important in itself, I do of course I'm
a biodiversity activist, but it's entirely
connected, saving the Arctic is entirely connected
to solving all the other problems around the
world as well.
>>Jenny Ross: And to just give you a few specific
examples: sea level rise, as Kassie mentioned,
now that's not from the Arctic sea ice melting
'cause that's ice that's floating on ocean;
we'll get approximately 23, 24 feet of sea
level rise from the melting of the Greenland
ice cap and that doesn't even include Antarctica.
If we lose all of that land ice we're looking
at sea level rise in the range of 230 feet;
entire countries will be under water.
And long before that, major cities, major
coastal cities, will be flooded.
Imagine permanent flooding throughout downtown
Manhattan.
Apart from flooding there is going to be an
increased incident of very severe storms of
various kinds, chronic severe droughts, shortages
of fresh water, shortages of food related
to the failure of agriculture because huge
regions that are now productive land are gonna
be transformed into essentially desiccated
deserts, wide spread extinction of species,
ocean acidification because the oceans absorb
a lot of that carbon dioxide from the air
and that causes the water to acidify and as
the water becomes more acid that destroys
the ability of many creatures to function
at all and some of them that build shells
can't build their shells anymore and that's
gonna disrupt the entire ocean food chain.
So if we wipe out a lot of the marine food
chain, I don't know what the percentage is,
I think it's like 80 to 85 percent of people
on our planet rely on protein from the oceans
for their food.
So you can see that one thing leads to another
leads to another leads to another and as I
said the implications are staggering; they
will affect literally every living thing on
earth including every population of people
all around the globe.
[pause]
>>male #3: So sort of on a slightly different
topic but can you describe how you take these
wonderful pictures --
[laughter]
how you find yourself on the Zodiac, fight
off the polar bears so they don't eat you.
>>Jenny Ross: [laughs] Well there's a lot
of variation in what is involved depending
on the specific location and specific circumstances.
For some of those photographs I was in a Zodiac
down at polar bear level; in some situations
I'm on the ground on the ice, sometimes in
a vehicle, sometimes in a larger boat, just
totally depends on the specific location and
the circumstances.
But as far as having to fight off polar bears
is concerned, yes of course they are carnivores
but they would much rather eat a seal than
a person.
So I've never been in a situation where I
felt threatened.
Of course I'm very careful but it's not as
if polar bears are out looking for people
to eat.
>>male #4: Well you had a lot of pictures
of young cubs, I imagine you got close to
one of those [unintelligible].
>>Jenny Ross: Sure.
You have to again be very, very careful.
It's important to understand behavior, not
only to be able to take photographs that communicate
interesting and useful things to people, but
also so that you can behave appropriately
in proximity to bears.
So because every bear is an individual they
don't all react the same way, they have different
levels of tolerance for people being in proximity
and you have to be sensitive to that.
Reading them is essential.
And I never put myself into a situation where
I'm close and I have no exit strategy.
So in a lot of those photographs of mothers
and cubs it appears that I'm very, very close
but I'm in the Zodiac and they're at the edge
of the sea ice so I have the ability to back
off if I need to.
And I'm also most of the time, not all the
time, but much of the time I'm using a very
long lens so I'm not quite as close as it
appears that I am.
[pause]
>>male #5: What' the strategy for [unintelligible]
countries outside of America [unintelligible]
>>Kassie Siegel: Well I'm sorry to say that
the U.S. has long been a laggard and that
the rest of the world is actually doing a
lot more, most of the rest of the world is
doing a lot more than the U.S.
So the main forum for that is the U.N. Framework
Convention on Climate Change, international
climate talks.
In 1992 the whole world agreed to take the
actions necessary to avoid dangerous climate
change, the U.S. Senate ratified that agreement,
also in there is the notion of common but
differentiated responsibilities, that is the
rich developed countries of the world caused
the problem, they will take the lead in solving
the problem.
We signed that, we ratified it, the first
binding, concrete agreement to reduce emissions
was in 1997 the Kyoto Protocol.
When the Clinton Administration negotiated
that treaty they actually got a lot of concessions
from the rest of the world in terms of making
the emissions reduction smaller and how those
reductions would be achieved, but after signing
the agreement in Kyoto the U.S. Senate, it
was never submitted to the U.S. Senate for
ratification because the U.S. Senate voted
95 to 0 in a non-binding resolution that the
U.S. shouldn't do anything unless the rest
of the world also took on binding targets.
Kyoto Protocol has binding, mandatory reductions
from the developed countries of the world,
while the developing countries would take
other actions as they try to reduce their
emissions' intensity while they continue to
develop.
I'm sorry to say that since '97 things have
continued to devolve, be happy to talk about
it more after the talk if you'd like, but
it is just, the U.S. has been blocking progress
at those talks and a lot of the rest of the
world is going on and doing more without the
U.S.
But we need to change things domestically
here and I think that's the number one thing
that will jump start international progress.
And I think we should wrap it up 'cause we're
a little over time.
So thank you so much everyone for coming.
>>Jenny Ross: Thanks very much.
[applause]